dans l'unité de médecine ambulatoire les
salles ont été refaites à neuf nouveaux
espaces et nouveau fauteuil pour assurer
notamment le suivi des personnes
souffrant d'obésité depuis un an à
l'hôpital de rambouillet on décide
d'opérer ou non un patient atteint de
cette maladie après un parcours de 6
mois minimum on sait beaucoup sur
l'opération et c'est vrai que c'est un
élément important
mais la partie qu'il ya un avant et
celle qui est la partie qui dit à avant
et c'est qu'il est après ce que nous on
a essayé de structure par ce parcours
est également importante les meilleurs
résultats en termes de perte de poids
des pertes de pain à long terme en
lacans donne à ce type de parcours
trois rendez-vous en eau
jour préopératoire sont prévus pour
faire examiner par plusieurs
spécialistes le patient avant validation
en gros groupes vraiment toutes les
spécialités dans le service au moment dé
hdj stallergènes intervention de
pratiquement toutes tous les corps de
métiers au niveau du service de médecine
ambulatoire
autre nouveauté dans l'hôpital le
développement de l'activité rythme aux
logiques sous spécialité de la
cardiologie c'est l'étude des anomalies
de la fréquence cardiaque et une vérité
pour tout le monde finalement c'est pour
les patients qui sont contents alors
juste pour l'anecdote en général les
patients quand on leur dit on va vous
changer un pacemaker quiconque on les
voit en consultation et dès qu'on leur
dit qu'on peut faire cette activité à
rambouillet ils sont très contents et
ils sont preneurs de le faire ici parce
que c'est juste à côté de chez eux
finalement en 1 mois 3 stimulateur
cardiaque appelé aussi pacemaker ont
déjà été posées et deux ont été changés
une nouvelle corde à l'arc du service
cardiologie et pneumologie en
perpétuelle agrandissement dans
l'hôpital je fais à l'hôpital de
rambouillet depuis 93
à l'époque
il n'y avait pas de service de
cardiologie ou un peu en fait l'activité
de services
s'est majoré c'est une fierté et bien
sûr
aboutissement prochaine étape en 2022
avec le développement d'un service de
rhumatologie aujourd'hui absents dans le
sud du département des spécialités qui
se poursuivront dans le projet du nouvel
hôpital prévue d'ici huit ans